present by we'll deliver a stark warning
to the unvaccinated later this afternoon
as what else is new as he unveils new
actions to battle the covet surge in
this new variant let's bring in former
cdc director current senior medical
advisor at am llc dr robert redfield dr
redfield always great to see you if you
were writing the script for the
president today what are the some of the
bullet points that you would like to get
across to the american people
thanks brian thanks for having me here
first and foremost i think the critical
thing is to remind the american people
that vaccines do work
the challenge with the vaccine is you
got to maintain them so obviously
maintaining your vaccination state with
additional
injections is fundamental second thing i
think we've really got to finally
embrace the tool of what i call
knowledge of infection and what that
means is we need to have expanded
testing
we need to be able to let people
understand if they're the silent
epidemic so they can pull themselves out
of the transmission pool rather than
treat everybody as if they may be
infected why don't we start focusing on
the people that are infected by expanded
testing substantial increase in testing
which i know the president's going to
talk about but i think really our nation
probably needs over a billion tests a
month just from a public health point of
view so we still have a long way to go
finally i hope that there'll be a a real
aggressive push on a private public
partnership to accelerate antiviral
development both to retool the
monoclonal antibodies that we've lost
with the
omicron variant but also to get the
private sector to build upon what we've
seen with merck and visor bringing
antivirals to bear let's get more
antivirals into the system right and
lastly i think it's really important
that we move to sort of a culture of
personal responsibility i'm not a big
advocate for mandates i don't think
mandates help terrible i think when you
tell people they have to do something
that they may be reluctant to do then
they become more reluctant so i think we
need a culture of you know personal
responsibility for us to understand what
mitigation steps we need to use for
ourselves and the different environments
we're in so those are my four major
points and i hope the president hits all
of them you also want to expedite the
pfizer
which could be something we all take up
i was in contact i'm starting to feel
symptoms let me take this some there's
some reason there's no urgency to get
this to market
yeah brian i think this is really
important i don't know where the
pressure points are
i know i had an opportunity to be the
cdc director during the beginning of
this pandemic i will tell you there was
a great sense of urgency
i was a part of the operation warp speed
board to bring vaccines to the american
public there was a great sense of
urgency
i don't see the same urgency in bringing
the diagnostic test to the american
public that we need as i mentioned we
probably need over a billion tests a
month i don't see that urgency and i
don't see the urgency in bringing
antivirals to the marketplace and we
need to really accelerate that sense of
urgency all right dr redfield
we should not be pretending am i correct
that omnicron is as lethal as the
original pandemic or the delta variant
should we be looking at what we know
right now and react accordingly
low-grade fever runny nose no deaths
yeah brian i think you're right that you
know when these viruses evolve and i
think you know i predicted it on fox
news probably four or five months ago i
said we're going to have another variant
it's going to be more transmissible than
delta
and i anticipate it'll become less
pathogenic that's what these viruses are
going to do we're going to have another
virus after
omicron and it's going to be more
transmissible than omicron and hopefully
it will become even less pathogenic than
omicron this virus is different from the
original strains in that it replicates
more in the upper respiratory tract
you know as opposed to lower lungs and
so it's causing much less disease that
said
in vulnerable individuals you know it
still has to keep sure you're putting
people in the hospital and still has the
capability of death but uh the real
issue with this pathogen is that it's
just so much more infection
so much more infectious
right uh but we should treat it uh
accordingly and not overreact to it and
you would like to see more tests and you
would like to see more therapeutics or
antiviral let's get some urgency there
and you're a pro uh dr robert redfield
thanks so much
yeah thanks brian great all right have a
great christmas you too sir thank you hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now